no it's not okay  I know a lot of people think it is but  it's really not  meaning do you  everyone's in control of their own  destiny in life but [ __ ] this right here  holding a [ __ ] Grudge it's [ __ ] up  so many of you I have family and friends  and business acquaintances holding  grudges as if it's doing anything to the  person that they're [ __ ] mad at  meanwhile it's [ __ ] killing them  inside [ __ ] letting that Darkness  manifest  this is like a [ __ ] first question  when you like I wanted to look up Grudge  and this is the first [ __ ] that comes up  on Google people really want to justify  their [ __ ] grudges  think about that that's because they  [ __ ] deep down know that [ __ ] is  [ __ ] poison  it's [ __ ] poison  go forgive someone Watch what it does  for you